lui c'est crypto bouffe les maris les
promenades et 4 le meilleur ami de
superman ils sont comme des frères
veille bien sûr notre fils
est lui aussi a des pouvoirs ensemble
ils font des trucs trop stylé mais
qu'est ce que j'ai pu trouver
mieux que ce soit en produits dérivés
officiels sinon je te bien méchant mais
tous les animaux n'ont pas la même
chanson ni senti bien n'être pas fait
pas trop d'illusions ils choisissent
presque toujours
c'est trop marrant
jusqu'au jour où
une bande d'animaux abandonnés devient
une bande de super à niveau du four je
devrais être beaucoup plus mort que ça
non
on n'est qu'une bande d'animaux 100 m
fixe
[Musique]
et on est plus fort que ce que tu crois
il vaudrait mieux car et vous devoir
affronter la pire des menaces je suis
lui et tu vas tu agenouillé devant moi
espèce de
[Musique]
oh
car toi d'là chatons il m'a sauvé la vie
maintenant je vais apprendre les mots
voilà que tu vas bien
ça va le faire